[Music]
so I'm here at dig this Las Vegas it's a
construction equipment playground where
you can live out your childhood dreams
of being able to operate heavy machinery
like bulldozers and excavators but first
gotta sign some waivers gonna take a
breathalyzer test which is very
important and you got to put on this
vest here for safety reasons before I
head out to the playground I have to
take a 10 to 15 minute safety training
course to make sure I'm safe out there
that's it that's the safety course I
guess I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
I named jr. Din I am an instructor and I
teach people how to have fun and have
the equipment that I've never been on
any equipment in their life
[Music]
locate that cab lift I think to the left
as hard as you can there is you ready to
do that pushing for what
[Music]
[Music]
Ben is such a blast I mean it's so cool
to be in charge of such a big powerful
machine did you get your mind off life
for a moment I did yes when I was moving
that dirt and stacking those tires it
was just a way for me to like kind of
zone out you know those focus on simple
tasks and that's what we want you to
eyes to do when you come out to Vegas
just have fun and tapping her inner
child again have fun thank you so much
that was great what was the biggest
challenge out there the biggest
challenge for you I would say just
getting a ride from left down